[موسيقى]
قدم مصمم الازياء اللبناني اللي صعب
مجموعته الجديده للخريف والشتاء القادمين
ضمن فعاليات اسبوع الازرق الباريسي مجموعه
بدات كلوحه شتويه مزهره او حقلا مزهر في
لوحه زيتيه معلقه في احد متاحف الايطاليه
عارضات ازياء قطع صعب لدينا مشرقات قويات
الشخصيه وجريئات وحرات يتمشين على منصه
العرض بثقه وانوثه
[موسيقى]
هو الاستروحه الاساسي دائما هو من جمال
المراه صوف المراه حلوه
وهالانسيابيه هل ساتين الطوال والالوان
نقلناهم هالمره بس اللي هو الاساسي من شان
الاستوديو كان انه كانه لوحه شتويه
[موسيقى]
بدات القطع وكانها زخارف زهريه رومانسيه
متنوعه بالوانها الكثيفه وضع عليها طبيعات
داكنه اللون بالتدرجات الزمرد العميق
واخضر الغابات الليلي الصامت عبايات شفافه
وتطريزات مشغوله يدويه
ناعم
كسلات يتقاطع المخمل مع الحرير في بعض قطع
المجموعه ليطفي انوثه على الاطلالات
الفارسيه الانيقه
[تصفيق]
[موسيقى]
انا دائما سعيد بقبول دعوه ايلي صعب لحضور
عرض ازياءه الذي اصبح صديقا قريبا وانا
فرح بوجود هنا لدي شغف لمشاهده ما يحوق
اليوم وانا متشوق لمشاهده قطعه
ومهني يعرف جيدا ان يضع المراه بمظهر
رائع
[موسيقى]
الاحمر المتجدد والاصفر المضيء كان جزءا
من عرض ازياء لصعب هذا الموسم اما الحقائب
فتزينت بالازهار الجلديه المتداخله مع
اناقه الاحذيه ذات الكعوب الشفافه مع حضور
لافتا
وتتميز بعض الاطلالات بلمسه عصريه حملت
توقيع صانع القبعات الايطالي بورسالينو
[موسيقى]
ليت بزاري باريس